Nous sommes en train de considérer les fruits de l'esprit qui est présenté par l'apôtre Paul au Galate comme une manière de décrire leurs conditions actuelles après la conversion.
C'est une église qui risquait de ne plus être en train de manifester les fruits de l'esprit. Une portion des personnes présentes dans cette église étaient en train de sacrifier la joie de leur liberté en Christ et en Christ seul en essayant de revenir à une relation avec Dieu qui n'était pas basée sur tout ce que Christ avait déjà accompli.
Mais qui était basée sur la performance religieuse des personnes, des personnes qui voulaient transpirer pour conquérir l'amour de Dieu, qui étaient déjà acquis et qui étaient déjà expérimentés par ceux qui, tout simplement par la foi en Christ et exclusivement par la foi en Christ, avaient déjà goûté et expérimenté la joie d'être devenus enfants de Dieu, d'être traités comme enfants de Dieu,
de respirer l'atmosphère de l'assurance du salut.
Mais ils étaient en train de sacrifier cette joie et cette liberté car ils étaient en train de subir l'oppression des judaïsants, des personnes qui voulaient suggérer, Christ, il était nécessaire et suffisant pour les saluts.
Mais pour maintenir votre salut, ne plus perdre votre salut, vous devez transpirer et faire des efforts selon la loi.
Et de l'autre côté, il y avait certains qui avaient mieux compris, au moins théologiquement,
le fait que Christ, dans son œuvre, est suffisant et satisfaisant pour pourvoir toute la justice, toute la sainteté qu'on ne peut jamais produire par nos efforts, même avec la loi.
Cette justice qu'on ne peut pas présenter devant Dieu pour être pardonné.
Ils ont compris que Christ avait tout accompli.
Par contre, ils étaient tentés, surtout devant la menace des judaïsants,
de se dire, comme Christ a tout accompli, nous pouvons même nous livrer au péché.
Et donc Paul, sa thèse, ou l'une de ses thèses principales pour corriger les Galates,
c'est de dire que ni libertinage, ni légalisme représentent les vrais évangiles.
Et les vrais enfants des dieux n'ont pas besoin de menaces légalistes pour se sanctifier, d'un côté.
Et un vrai chrétien des dieux, il est tellement né des dieux et né pour Dieu,
qu'il va volontairement et progressivement progresser en sainteté.
Donc ni les libertins peuvent être véritablement chrétiens, ni les légalistes.
Et donc l'apôtre Paul fait un rappel, car il était plutôt assuré du fait que les Galates, ils étaient vraiment chrétiens.
Et les sceaux de leur conversion étaient la présence de Saint-Esprit.
Et Saint-Esprit qui a pour but principal, nous unir à Christ d'une manière tellement expérimentale et consciente,
que la vie du Christ commence à se manifester dans nos vies.
Il opère une nouvelle naissance où notre volonté prédominante profonde, c'est de plaire Dieu, de nous sanctifier.
Et il pourvoit aussi les influences et la puissance pour qu'on puisse progresser en sainteté.
Paul était convaincu que les Galates avaient commencé bien la course, qu'ils avaient les Saint-Esprit.
Et c'est un rappel qu'il fait.
Les fruits de l'Esprit, donc au lieu de rentrer dans tous les détails de vos débats, de vos discussions, de vos disputes internes,
au lieu de faire confiance à moi-même, l'apôtre Paul,
comme si je pouvais venir vous visiter et passer des mois et des mois à écouter chacun de vous,
ce que vous avez contre quelqu'un,
ou ce que quelqu'un a contre vous,
je préfère faire confiance à la présence de Saint-Esprit chez vous.
Je ne vais pas vous traiter comme des petits bébés spirituels,
comme si moi, dans ma capacité en tant qu'être humain,
je pourrais vous aider à régler toutes vos petites problématiques.
Ils étaient en train de se dévorer.
Les frères et sœurs au sein d'une même église.
Et pour promouvoir cette réconciliation, il suffit d'apporter une exhortation, un rappel très important.
Si vous voulez vous considérer véritablement chrétien,
rappelez-vous que vous devez manifester les fruits d'Esprit.
C'est un fruit organique.
Ce n'est pas une liste des choses à faire.
C'est un constat.
C'est quelque chose d'accessible.
Ce qui donne de l'espérance pour nous, qui fait notre joie,
c'est de savoir que, même si on sera exhorté à la mesure où on considère les facettes du fruit de l'Esprit,
car pendant certaines périodes, ces choses peuvent manquer,
à cause de notre carnalité, à cause du reste du péché dans nos vies.
Mais c'est un signe de faiblesse grossière par rapport à toutes les ressources qui sont à notre disposition en tant que chrétien.
Les dieux tout-puissants, la troisième personne de la Trinité, habitent en nous.
Et il est là intéressé à pourvoir ses vertus.
Et donc, c'est une exhortation très puissante d'un côté,
car si on n'a pas ça, on ne va pas hériter les règles des dieux.
On ne peut pas se considérer enfant des dieux.
Mais ces choses, elles sont accessibles, possibles,
et elles ont déjà été expérimentées par tous les chrétiens.
Donc la question ici, c'est que nous sommes devant la description de ce qui est les chrétiens.
Et les chrétiens, c'est lui en qui le Saint-Esprit habite et produit ses fruits.
Donc la grande vérité de toute la section pour nous,
c'est que les fruits de l'Esprit sont nécessaires et suffisants pour identifier un vrai enfant des dieux.
Et aucune église et aucun chrétien ne peut confirmer sa propre foi ou la foi de quelqu'un,
à moins qu'il soit en train de manifester les fruits de l'Esprit.
Si ces choses ne sont pas là,
nous risquons de chercher les convents qui sont chrétiens lorsqu'ils ne sont pas.
Et donc ces choses doivent être présentes.
Et cette exhortation a suffi pour que les Galates se redressent.
C'est l'espoir pour nous.
Et ce qu'on a considéré, c'est que pour nous, c'est très important de savoir identifier les fruits de l'Esprit,
car les vertus ici présentées ne sont pas naturelles.
Elles ne peuvent qu'être présentes dans ce qui sont dans l'Esprit.
Donc pour plus qu'on connaisse la joie, la paix, l'amour,
dans une certaine mesure dans toute l'humanité,
par rapport au reste de l'image des dieux,
c'est clair qu'ici nous sommes devant un fruit spirituel produit par les Saint-Esprit.
Donc c'est dans notre ordre,
d'une autre nature.
Mais les fruits, ils sont aussi organiques.
Ce n'est pas quelque chose qu'on puisse produire de nous-mêmes par nos propres efforts.
C'est les Saint-Esprits qui doivent être là.
Ce sont des vertus surtout spirituelles qui vont se manifester de manière visible,
mais qui découlent de cette racine qui est notre union avec Christ par les Saint-Esprits.
Ce sont des choses qui seront toujours permanentes chez tous les chrétiens,
même si elles peuvent osciller dans leur intensité,
car les Saint-Esprits sont un don donné d'une fois pour toutes,
irrévocable à ceux qui l'ont vraiment reçu.
Et même si les Saint-Esprits sont permanents pour être toujours là,
pour pouvoir les influence,
et la puissance pour qu'on puisse progresser dans la manifestation de ces fruits,
nous sommes une nouvelle créature qui participe volontairement et responsablement
dans la manière dont on doit cultiver des influences de Saint-Esprit
et donc les fruits de Saint-Esprit.
En ayant considéré donc les fruits de l'Esprit de manière générale
par rapport à ses fonctionnements,
nous sommes passés à la considération de chacune de ces facettes.
La première qu'on a considérée, c'était l'amour.
C'est les premiers de la liste.
Et on a considéré en fait que l'amour est la vertu capitale,
toute intégratrice,
de laquelle dépendent toutes les autres facettes de ces fruits,
un fruit indivisible, inséparable.
Donc c'est une personne aimée, c'est une personne qui aime,
la personne qui va manifester le fait qu'elle est aimée
et qu'elle aime par la joie, la paix, la patience, la bonté, etc.
Et donc on a compris que c'est surtout la compréhension
et l'expérience de cet amour
qui est l'amour salvateur des dieux manifesté en Jésus-Christ
par les Saint-Esprits.
C'est profondément objectif, concret,
mais c'est aussi profondément expérimental.
Et ensuite, on est passé à considérer
cette deuxième facette, cette deuxième vertu.
Et donc la vérité pour nous,
c'est que la joie est une vertu capitale du fruit de l'Esprit aussi.
Et afin de constater et maximiser la manifestation
de la joie de l'Esprit,
les chrétiens doivent identifier dans leur vie
et cultiver intentionnellement
la joie du Saint-Esprit.
Et la question qu'on se pose, c'est
qui devons-nous savoir à propos de la joie du Saint-Esprit
afin qu'on soit capable
de constater cette réalité dans nos vies
et de maximiser cette réalité dans nos vies.
Vous êtes avec moi ?
Et donc, la première vérité,
les deux premières vérités,
on a considéré les dimanches derniers.
La première, c'est que pour connaître,
pardon, pour maximiser
et constater la joie de l'Esprit,
chez nous,
les chrétiens doivent connaître
et avoir un désir profond et progressif
pour expérimenter, manifester
et cultiver cette joie.
Donc, si les fruits de l'Esprit
sont une évidence de ceux qui sont
véritablement nés des dieux,
de ceux qui sont convertis,
cette facette doit être présente
dans la vie de tous les chrétiens.
Donc, la joie est une marque distinctive
!
des vrais chrétiens.
C'est-à-dire que tous les chrétiens
et que les vrais chrétiens
ont déjà expérimenté cette joie,
la joie de cette nature.
Peut-être que vous avez dérouté,
que vous êtes affaibli aujourd'hui,
peut-être que votre vie est plus marquée
par la tristesse que par la joie.
Mais au moins,
tous les vrais chrétiens
doivent pouvoir identifier
un moment dans leur vie,
dans les passés,
et la réalité,
que la compréhension,
que cette joie est à sa portée
encore aujourd'hui,
c'est sans soi l'espoir.
Donc, la première question
qu'on doit se poser,
est-ce qu'on a déjà goûté
de cette joie
qui est d'une autre nature,
qui surmonte à l'infini
tous les plaisirs
qu'on puisse goûter sur terre?
C'est une joie
qui a un fondement raisonnable,
l'œuvre parfaite du Christ,
l'union avec Christ,
les pardons de nos péchés,
accès à la présence de Dieu.
Il n'y a pas de raison
supérieure
pour nous jouir
dans cette vie.
De l'autre côté,
c'est aussi profondément expérimental.
C'est possible
de connaître l'évangile,
d'expliquer l'évangile
de manière théorique,
de manière précise,
sans avoir expérimenté
cette joie.
La joie,
par nature,
est profondément expérimentale.
Elle ne peut pas être cachée.
La joie,
elle est non seulement
une marque distinctive
des chrétiens,
mais elle est aussi
la force
de l'âme.
La joie de l'éternel
est notre force.
Et c'est aussi
l'une des puissances
les plus efficaces
pour l'évangélisation.
Si vous voulez vous demander
dans la génération
pourquoi on est plus efficace
dans l'évangélisation,
ce n'est pas car
on ne connaît
pas plus à propos
des arguments scientifiques,
apologétiques,
si on aura
plus de contextualisation
à faire
pour communiquer
l'évangile
avec plus de clarté.
Je pense qu'on peut trouver
des hommes suffisamment
capables
dans les cercles chrétiens
pour se battre
de manière raisonnable
contre toutes ces philosophies
vaines
des nantes générations.
Mais l'un des problèmes
avec les chrétiens
des nantes générations,
c'est les manques des joies.
C'est une génération
des chrétiens
qui a cédé
aux pressions
hédonistes.
Les plaisirs
pour aujourd'hui
et maintenant
et si les circonstances
ne vont pas,
mon attente
envers la joie
dépend plus
du changement
des circonstances
qu'il est la réalité
objective et suprême
qui est la base
et les fondements
de notre joie.
La théologie
de la prospérité
c'est l'un des plus grands
ennemis de la joie chrétienne
que au lieu
de nous conduire
l'égard
envers la richesse
que nous avons déjà
en Dieu,
elle concentre
nos égards
sur les choses
qu'on n'a pas encore
et qu'on devrait
avoir plus.
Insatisfaction.
C'est l'opposé
de l'expérience
des conversions
de la femme samaritaine
par exemple.
Débourdante de joie.
C'est l'opposé
de l'expérience
de la joie
de l'apôtre Paul
et Pierre
emprisonnés,
battus.
Joie inéphable.
Dans une prison.
Écrire la lettre
de l'allégresse
philippienne
en exhortant
les chrétiens
en dehors
en liberté.
Réjouissez-vous
une autre fois
je vous l'ai dit
réjouissez-vous
vous dans les seigneurs.
Donc,
c'est un thème
très pertinent
pour nous
mais nous devons
être clairs
si nous voulons
nous considérer
chrétiens
et si nous voulons
maximiser
notre expérience
des joies
et par là
maximiser
notre expérience
des vies.
Dans un sens
ou autre
toutes les personnes
sont à la fin des comptes
à la recherche
du bonheur.
et nous avons trouvé
des vrais bonheurs
et nous devrions
rester accrochés
à ces bonheurs.
Et donc,
la joie de l'esprit
doit être une réalité
pour nos vies.
Elle est une réalité
perpétuelle
pour tous les vrais chrétiens
et nous devons identifier
chez nous
au moins
une fois
où cette expérience
était concrète
pour nous
mais nous devons
identifier aussi
chez nous
attention
vous pouvez ne pas
être en train
de vivre
les mêmes réveils
qu'un jour
vous avez goûté
au moment de votre conversion
mais si
le désir
de revenir
au premier amour
n'est pas
la chose
la plus prédominante
dans nos vies
si ce n'est pas
la chose
qui vous donne
encore les forces
pour continuer
à endurer
et persévérer
vous n'avez pas goûté
encore cette joie
c'est salut.
Le salut
est caractérisé
par cette transition
d'un empire des ténèbres
d'addiction
au plaisir mondant
envers
goûter
les royaumes
des lumières
dans les visages
du Christ
et donc
il faut que ces désirs
soient profonds
qu'ils soient résolus
qu'ils soient
continus
chez nous
et qu'ils soient
progressifs
donc les chrétiens
ils doivent savoir
qu'il a déjà
expérimenté
et ils doivent
savoir
que les désirs
les plus profonds
de son âme
c'est de trouver
cette joie
de retrouver
de se maintenir
accrochée
à cette joie
ensuite on a considéré
que nous devons
afin d'identifier
et de maximiser
notre expérience
avec la joie chrétienne
nous devons
connaître
l'authenticité
et l'efficacité
de la joie
face aux œuvres
de la chair
et les contrefaçon
et les contrefaçons
de l'évangile
donc l'apôtre Paul
à nouveau
il fait un rappel
à tous ces chrétiens
en Galate
de la joie chrétien
de la joie chrétienne
dans leur passé
verset 19
jusqu'au verset 21
juste avant
qu'au verset 22
ils disent
mais les fruits de l'esprit
c'est à dire que
chacune des facettes
du fruit de l'esprit
est mise en opposition
comme
supérieure
une force supérieure
et
vaincante
contre
toutes les œuvres
de la chair
et donc
c'est intéressant
de remarquer
dans la liste des péchés
on sait que ce n'est pas
une liste exhaustive
des œuvres de la chair
l'apôtre Paul
va présenter
certaines qui sont
plus caractéristiques
des péchés
des libertinages
des débauches
et d'autres
qui sont plus caractéristiques
des hypocrites
pharisiens
judaïsants
nous pouvons être
débarrassés
des actes concrets
d'immoralité sexuelle
des déviations d'argent
d'addictions
aux entorpeçants
et en même temps
être complètement
esclaves de la chair
accrochées
à une foi
ou une religion
hypocrite
où
on s'enorgueillit
de notre justice propre
comme si on était
véritablement capable
d'accomplir
la loi des dieux
et donc ici
l'apôtre Paul
il va présenter la joie
comme capable
de surmonter
de détruire
et de supprimer
toutes ces œuvres
de la chair
par exemple
d'un côté
il va s'adresser
aux légalistes
pharisiens
lorsqu'il va
mentionner
par exemple
les inimitiés
les querelles
les jalousies
les animosités
les disputes
les divisions
les sectes
l'envie
là il est en train
de s'opposer
aux légalistes
qui vont suggérer
que les saluts
se donnent par
l'observation de la loi
ou les nomistes
ceux qui disent
ok donc vous êtes
sauvés par Christ
mais maintenant
vous avez besoin
de vos efforts
pour ne pas perdre
votre salut
ou pour progresser
en santé
ces deux concepts
représentent
les légalismes
pharisaïques
judaïsants
de son époque
qui sont des contrefaçons
pour les vrais évangiles
et ces œuvres
chanelles
c'est intéressant
de remarquer
inimitié
querelle
jalousie
animosité
etc
c'est les résultats
d'une quête
inatteinable
pour la justice
par ses propres efforts
les personnes
deviennent
les policiers
de la foi
ils sont
névrotiques
car ils sont
dans une atmosphère
où Dieu
n'est pas un père
Dieu est la
personnification
de la loi
c'est comme si
la loi
était Dieu
lui-même
et une loi
très intéressée
à répondre
très vite
à notre incapacité
de l'obéir
l'accomplir
par des menaces
et donc
dans cette atmosphère
ces personnes-là
ont plutôt
l'envie
au début
de verset 21
c'est une envie
envers
attention
la joie
des chrétiens
authentiques
ils sont particulièrement
intéressés
à juger
ceux qui ne rentrent pas
dans la moule
dans les fardeaux
très lourds
de toutes les petites lois
qu'ils ont rajoutées
à la loi
pour donner l'impression
par l'extérieur
par la quantité
de tissus
qui couvrent leur corps
par la privation
des plaisirs légitimes
ils ont l'envie
envers
quelqu'un
qui a sorti
d'un arrière-plan
des débauches
d'addictions
et qui n'a pas
encore tout compris
qui n'a pas
changé
visiblement
à l'extérieur
beaucoup de choses
mais qui a déjà
progressé
des milliers
de kilomètres
envers sa progression
en sanctification
qu'est les policiers
de la foi
qu'est les légalistes
donc leur envie
est l'envie
envers la joie
du vrai chrétien
leur envie
est l'envie
de la liberté
du vrai chrétien
de celui
qui est
sûr
de l'amour
paternel
des dieux
envers lui
un amour d'alliance
qu'il ne peut pas perdre
!
et qui suffit
pour que lui
si jamais
il tombe
dans un péché
il est plus motivé
à confesser
son péché
et progresser
davantage
dans sa course
par l'assurance
du pardon
du père
comme les fils prodigues
que par les menaces
de perdre
son salut
ou d'être traité
comme un patron
envers un esclave
Mais Paul
il va aussi
s'adresser
à l'autre extrême
les contrefaçons
opposées
les antinomiants
ceux qui
d'une manière
un peu théologique
vont chercher
à dire
on n'a plus besoin
de la loi
car Christ a tout
accompli
ou les libertants
qui a causé
leur tentation
envers les péchés
ils vont dire
c'est la grâce
bon marché
Christ même
malgré tout
donc je me livre
au péché
et là Paul
est en train
de dire
non
si le Saint-Esprit
habite en vous
si vous êtes
vraiment enfant
des dieux
votre plaisir
c'est de faire
la volonté
du père
et par l'amour
à Christ
vous allez progresser
en sainteté
et c'est intéressant
de remarquer
comment la joie
est le seul moyen
pour détruire
ses oeuvres
car la joie
de quelqu'un
qui était convaincu
d'avoir été pardonné
parfaitement
Christ
c'est une joie
qui ne se porte pas
envers les autres
par l'initié
les querelles
les jalousies
etc
la joie
des pharisiens
ou les pharisiens
sont plutôt caractérisés
par la non-joie
ou la vaine joie
la vaine gloire
de verset 26
et la vraie joie
est cette assurance
du pardon paternel
des dieux
et de l'autre côté
on sait très bien
que la seule chose
qui peut nous délivrer
des plaisirs charnels
comme l'impudicité
l'impureté
la dissolution
l'immoralité sexuelle
l'idolâtrie
ou la magie
c'est ce qui est très intéressant
car c'est antinomien
dans le sens
où Dieu nous interdit
d'avoir d'autres idoles
et les rapports
envers toutes les choses
créées
qui placent ces choses
au lieu des dieux
ou la relation plurielle
envers les religions
comme tous les schémas
pourraient amener un dieu
c'est charnel
car c'est à service
toujours
d'une espèce
d'insatisfaction
envers les vrais dieux
si les vrais dieux
n'est pas capable
de me satisfaire
s'il n'est pas digne
de ma totale
et exclusive confiance
je n'ai pas connu
le vrai dieu
et voilà pourquoi
je pense que je peux
venir à l'église
et après
consulter les tarots
ou les signes
ou des choses comme ça
abominable
le dieu
signe que les personnes
n'ont pas connu
le vrai dieu
car le vrai dieu
nous remplit tellement
de joie
il devient tellement digne
de notre totale
et exclusive confiance
on ne compare pas
les dieux chrétiens
avec les autres religions
il est le seul vrai dieu
il est infiniment
plus élevé
il est le seul
digne d'être appelé dieu
que ses natures
et donc l'ivronnerie
et les excès de table
démontrent aussi
les personnes
qui ne sont pas satisfaites
dans la pratique
ce qui pourvoit
pour moi
la capacité
de maîtriser mon corps
ce qui me donne
la possibilité
de dire non
au plaisir
d'extase
irrationnel
par les drogues
par exemple
par les entourpessants
par les psychotropes
c'est la réalité
d'avoir connu
une joie
qui surmonte
infiniment
ce type de plaisir
donc le chrétien
est le seul
qui peut dire non
à ces tentations
des plaisirs réels
mais infiniment inférieurs
car il a connu
un plaisir
d'un ordre
infiniment supérieur
donc vous comprenez
comment la joie
détruit
ses péchés
soit légaliste
soit
charnel
des débauches
et donc en ayant
traité ces choses
on va passer
à considérer
d'une manière
plus positive
ce qu'est la joie
car ça ne sert pas
à grande chose
d'être qu'il y a
dans l'exhortation
pour parler de la joie
et là on passe
au verset 22
pas dans sa relation
avec les versets précédents
mais plutôt
dans la considération
objective
les fruits de l'esprit
c'est l'amour
la joie
et donc la troisième chose
qu'on doit savoir
c'est que l'amour
de Dieu
est la source
suprême
de cette joie
c'est-à-dire
les croyants
doivent connaître
la joie de l'esprit
comme fondamentalement
enracinée
et intégralement
liée
à l'ensemble
du fruit de l'esprit
donc on a fait
une comparaison
entre cette joie
et les œufs de la chair
et maintenant
on va comprendre
la relation
entre cette joie
et l'ensemble
du fruit de l'esprit
d'un côté
comme on a dit
que l'amour
est la vertu capitale
donc la joie
elle est fondée
sur cet amour
elle découle
de cet amour
elle est nourrie
pour cet amour
car à la fin des comptes
dans l'expérience humaine
ce qui représente
pour nous
les plaisirs
les plus élevés
les plus capables
de véritablement
nous satisfaire
ne sont pas
les plaisirs
d'interaction
avec les choses
créées
les plaisirs
qui peuvent
tout simplement
satisfaire
les corps
mais ce sont
surtout
les plaisirs
relationnels
dans les champs
l'amour
et ici
nous sommes devant
la considération
de l'expérience
des joies
la plus sublime
nous sommes devant
une joie
qui sait
que les chrétiens
qui peut connaître
car ce sont
que les chrétiens
qui ont connu
cet amour
des dieux
révélé
en Christ
par le Saint-Esprit
un amour
des dieux
dirigé
envers nous
par Christ
expérimenté
par la réalité
du Saint-Esprit
à nouveau
un amour
qui a un fondement
solide
et qui est
non seulement
connu
par la raison
mais expérimenté
par l'esprit
des dieux
qui habite
chez les chrétiens
une joie
plus sublime
que celle-là
n'est pas
atteignable
c'est impossible
de concevoir
des relations
d'amour
supérieures
que l'amour
que Dieu révèle
envers un chrétien
donc comment
nous pouvons
mesurer cet amour
donc la Bible
elle nous montre
très clairement
la liaison
entre la joie
et l'amour
mais si nous observons
par exemple
qu'est-ce qu'on cherche
quand on veut
être aimé
donc on peut avoir
les plaisirs
par exemple
dans l'observation
d'un beau scénario
sentir un peu de joie
quand on voit
le soleil
s'approcher
on sent la chaleur
on peut sentir
les parfums
des roses
et c'est clair
qu'à chaque fois
qu'on a du plaisir
dans la vie
on arrive à maximiser
ses plaisirs
si on a d'autres
personnes
qui peuvent réjouir
moi par exemple
je ne me considère pas
un grand cuisinier
mais quand je fais
quelque chose de bon
je ne peux pas
aller manger tout seul
j'ai envie de partager
et on va tous faire
des éloges
à la bonne chose
ensemble
et ça maximise
la joie
pourquoi ?
car Dieu a créé
ces choses
pour maximiser
les relations
mais surtout
pour maximiser
les relations
avec lui-même
je me rappelle
très bien
le moment
où je me suis converti
moi j'étais
toujours lié
à la plage
au surf
donc j'avais
beaucoup de plaisir
dans l'interaction
avec la nature
mais après mon
expérience de conversion
je suis rentré
au contact
avec la nature
et c'est comme
si toutes les choses
brillaient
pour la première fois
j'avais quelqu'un
à dire merci
pour ces choses
ce n'était pas
qu'un plaisir
de réjouir
des bonnes choses
c'était un plaisir
de réjouir
des bonnes choses
sachant que
ces bonnes choses
m'ont été données
par un père
qui veut maximiser
son amour
pour moi
et ma relation
avec lui
en pouvant
réjouir
avec Dieu
des choses
qu'il a créées
pour notre plaisir
pour notre récréation
mais c'est clair
que
dans l'expérience
chrétienne
tout comme dans
une expérience
familiale
par exemple
ça ne veut pas
dire grande chose
si quelqu'un
me dit
par exemple
je ne vais pas
sauter des joies
si on me dit
qu'il rit clair
m'aime
et ça veut dire
beaucoup de choses
d'entendre
mon père m'a dit
qu'il m'aime
et en plus
si on considère
que la personne
de qui ma joie
dépend
lorsqu'il va manifester
son amour
envers moi
c'est une chose
de savoir
que mon père
ou ma mère
m'aime
de manière
inconditionnelle
sachant que
je ne suis pas
en train
de les plaire
ça me rassure
énormément
savoir que
je suis aimé
mais ma joie
ni sa joie
est au maximum
car mon père
et ma mère
peuvent m'aimer
malgré
les tristesses
que je suis en train
de provoquer
donc le sommet
de la joie
pour nous
c'est ce qu'on appelle
l'amour correspondant
être aimé
par une personne
qui importe
une personne
importante pour nous
une personne digne
et être capable
de plaire
son cœur
vous êtes avec moi ?
et donc nous pouvons
dans une relation
charnelle et utopique
faire des personnes
des idoles
on peut faire
de nos parents
nos idoles
on peut faire
d'un conjoint
un idole
d'une passion
d'adolescence
un idole
mais nous savons
que même si
ils ne nous aiment pas
comme on aimerait
qu'ils nous aiment
ils sont tous
imparfaits
ma joie
ne peut pas dépendre
de leur avis
à propos de ma vie
et si je dépends
d'être toujours
celui qui est parfait
pour plaire
ceux qui m'aiment
je ne trouverai
jamais non plus
ma joie
car je sais
que je suis incapable
d'être aimable
avec toute l'intensité
de ma vie
donc pourquoi
les chrétiens
sont les seuls
capables
d'expérimenter
la joie
ineffable
c'est qu'à
les chrétiens
ils sont tout simplement
aimés
à l'extrême
par la personne
la plus digne
et aimable
de l'univers
avec un amour
d'alliance
incassable
malgré
notre manque
d'amabilité
et assuré
d'être
rendu
pleinement aimable
par cet amour
divan
sublime
et les chrétiens
véritables
a connu
ce type
d'amour
je vais revenir
sur cette déclaration
car elle est très riche
en partie
et vous allez constater
l'importance
de la relation
entre doctrine
et joie
être aimé
à l'extrême
par l'être
le plus aimable
de l'univers
avec un amour
d'alliance
incassable
ici c'est
la doctrine
de la justification
par la foi
considérer
pourquoi
Dieu
est l'être
que si
si on savait
mesurer les faits
que
lui
est celui
qui m'aime
je devrais considérer
par exemple
que Dieu
est le seul
fondamental
légitime
pour la joie
il est appelé
dans la Bible
comme les dieux
bienheureux
c'est lui
qui dit
à chaque atome
dans les micro
univers
il va régir
c'est lui
qui a tout créé
et toutes les choses
disent
amén à sa volonté
dans les macrocosmos
c'est la même chose
il a créé
toutes les étoiles
il les appelle
par leur nom
il a créé
les choses
les plus complexes
et les choses
les plus simples
les choses
les plus belles
on pourrait imaginer
dans l'état
où les choses
ont été créées
très bonnes
à l'origine
il pourrait trouver
par exemple
son plaisir
comme il l'a dit
à chaque fois
tout est bon
tout est très bon
tout simplement
dans les choses
qui pourraient dépendre
de sa simple volonté
et de sa toute puissance
la beauté
c'est comme pour Achere
il dit des fois
pourquoi
Dieu a placé
une des fleurs
qui a la plus belle
au monde
en plein milieu
d'une forêt
complètement fermée
si personne
ne passe
pour la contempler
réponse
car lui
il la voit
les dieux
tout puissants
qui sont présentés
dans la bible
comme les saints
c'est à dire
il est en train
d'éclater
dans la beauté
de sa sainteté
il est élevé
la gloire des dieux
elle est comparée
au soleil
la pureté absolue
la lumière
lorsqu'il fait louir
sa face favorable
envers nous
nous trouvons
notre joie
vous comprenez
c'est les dieux créateurs
les dieux sublimes
les dieux bienheureux
c'est à dire
il n'y a pas de différence
entre sa volonté
et réalisation
nous
on manque des joies
parfois
car on pense
que notre joie
dépend de notre volonté
accomplie
déjà on n'a même pas
une volonté parfaite
on peut désirer
des choses mauvaises
pour nous
et encore moins
on n'a pas la capacité
d'assurer
que par nos efforts
on va faire
les choses passer
mais ce n'est pas
le même cas pour Dieu
il a une volonté parfaite
et cette volonté
va s'accomplir
c'est à dire
il est les dieux joyeux
les fondements
de la joie
l'expérience
nous montre ça
si on est à côté
de personnes
qui ne sont pas
joyeuses
on n'a pas envie
de rester
la joie est profondément
relationnelle
nous voulons
nous approcher
de Dieu
car on contemple
non la personnification
d'une loi
contre nous
on contemple
un Dieu
débordant
des joies
satisfait
qui n'est pas
en train de regarder
en dehors de lui-même
pour trouver des motifs
pour nous aimer
il est tout simplement
amour
et c'est lui-même
qui va pourvoir
la manière
de justifier
son amour
car bien sûr
est sans
sans sainteté
il n'y a pas
du vrai amour
car l'amour
et la sainteté
sont harmoniques
car la sainteté
n'est rien
que le mieux
pour nous
fonctionner
selon l'ordre
de la création
de celui
qui nous a créés
pour avoir
un but
qui maximise
notre joie
et donc
Dieu
dans la beauté
de sa sainteté
a décidé
de fixer
ses affections
envers son peuple
mais il nous a aimé
à l'extrême
dans quel sens
Dieu a tant aimé
les mondes
qu'il a donné
son fils
unique
les fils
appelés dans la Bible
de l'amour
du père
vous voyez la description
ce qui est
le plus aimable
pour Dieu
n'est pas
toute la création
mais celui
par qui
toutes les choses
ont été créées
et en qui
toutes choses
vont converger
pour manifester
sa gloire
c'est-à-dire
Dieu
il est les dieux
bienheureux
non car
il a pu créer
des bonnes choses
et des belles choses
en quoi
il pourrait se jouir
dans l'univers
de la création
mais il a été
toujours
pendant toute l'éternité
les dieux bienheureux
car les trois personnes
de la Trinité
sont toujours
en train d'interagir
dans une relation
attention
la relation personnelle
infiniment plus élevée
en termes de plaisir
que les choses
qu'ils puissent créer
et la Bible nous présente
les trois personnes
de la Sainte Trinité
étant parfaitement
et infiniment aimables
la volonté
dans la même direction
l'amabilité parfaite
l'éclat de gloire
la réjouissance
de cette profonde
intimité familiale
!
un amour assuré
un amour incassable
un amour dont l'alliance
est une alliance
des natures
des co-substances
des co-existences
voilà pourquoi
Dieu est le fondement
solide de la joie
et nous dans notre rébellion
tournant les deux
contre Dieu
pour nous accrocher
aux petites choses
de ces mondes
au lieu
de la source
de tous les biens
il a placé
ses affections
vers nous
et il nous a aimés
à l'extrême
il nous a aimés
car notre manque
d'amabilité
a été comblé
par la totale
amabilité
du fils
le Seigneur Jésus Christ
il vient
accomplir parfaitement
la loi
à notre place
mort à la croix
pour nous
et par la foi
en Christ
unis à Christ
nous sommes déjà
dans une position
devant Dieu
où
Dieu peut
dépenser sur nous
tout son amour
comme si on était
les Christus lui-même
notre vie est cachée
en Christ par la foi
vous êtes avec moi ?
une source de joie
incroyable
Dieu en disant
je t'aime
comme à mon propre fils
et car vous êtes unis
par son esprit
à mon fils
et car vous êtes couverts
de la droiture
de mon fils
devant moi
peu importe
l'oscillation
de votre vie
dans les progrès
rien ne peut changer
cet amour
envers toi
et attention
pour les chrétiens
c'est les cadres
parfaits
pour progresser
en santé
accès
à la présence
de Dieu
Dieu comme un père
qui ne va jamais
laisser de nous aimer
en plénitude
c'est lui
qui nous a prouvé
déjà son amour
en envoyant son fils
mais Dieu n'est pas
qui intéressé
tout simplement
à nous assurer
qu'aucune chose
ne va nous séparer
de son amour
il est intéressé
à pourvoir
ce que
les vrais chrétiens
nous on connait
comme on est
dans notre désir
le plus profond
c'est à dire
je ne veux pas
tout simplement
que Dieu m'aime
malgré moi
je veux que Dieu m'aime
non seulement
à cause de Christ
mais qu'il m'aime
en Christ
qu'il m'aime
car moi
je progresse
en santé
il m'aime
car moi
je progresse
dans la conformité
avec Jésus Christ
et donc
ces cadres
où Dieu nous dit
aucune chose
ne va jamais
te séparer
de mon amour
c'est le même cadre
qui va promouvoir
la puissance
donc c'est cet amour
de Dieu
et c'est ça
qui est intéressant
on voit les églises
qui veulent
supprimer
l'aspect
coupabilité
qui veulent supprimer
la pollution
et la corruption
de l'homme
les églises
du développement
personnel
de nos jours
c'est le type
déjà le plus
superficiel
qui existe
et la coupabilité
c'est essayer
d'être supprimé
à force
elle va toujours
réapparaître
et ça n'a pas
la capacité
de faire que les personnes
progressent
véritablement
dans la foi
mais la réalité
pour les chrétiens
c'est qu'on n'a pas
besoin de cacher
nos fautes
car Dieu nous aime
d'une fois pour toutes
à l'extrême
car nous sommes
cachés en Christ
et lui-même
pourvoit
les plaisirs
par cet amour
insistant vers nous
il pourvoit
les puissances
pour qu'on
se sanctifie
progressivement
ce qui fait
la joie
du chrétien
c'est cet amour
connu
de manière
objective
en Christ
dans l'évangile
et expérimental
par les saints
esprits
donc l'amour
est le fondement
de cette joie
et nous trouvons
cette réalité
dans plusieurs passages
comme Galates
chapitre 4
verset 4
remarquez bien
toutes les sources
des joies
sont rassurées
par un tel passage
Jésus-Christ
il vient
pour nous permettre
d'être insérés
dans un cadre
de relation avec Dieu
où rien ne manque
pour qu'on soit
accepté
et aimé
à l'extrême
mais en même temps
ce qui fait
notre joie
c'est savoir
que nous pouvons
être reçus
par Dieu
par un esprit
d'adoption
et le Saint-Esprit
de Dieu en nous
nous conduit
à crier
Abba Père
nous ne sommes
plus esclaves
mais fils
et aussi un héritier
similarité avec Dieu
assuré
et l'héritage
de tout l'univers
glorifié
assuré
donc c'est intéressant
de remarquer
cette transition
car les chrétiens
en Christ
ils trouvent
la joie
d'avoir
l'accessibilité
au trône des dieux
donc c'est la réalité
de la vie du chrétien
pourquoi
il est quelqu'un
sûr de soi
c'est intéressant
une personne
qui est sûr de soi
avant la conversion
elle a tort
elle finira à l'enfer
mais un chrétien
qui n'est pas
sûr de soi
en Christ
n'a pas compris
l'évangile
comme il faut non plus
comment on n'est pas
être une personne
bien résolue
envers la vie
comment on n'est pas
avoir
de la douceur
de la patience
de la tempérance
si nous avons
déjà tout
nous sommes déjà
tous ceux
que l'on aimerait être
la Bible
elle traite la réalité
future
de notre
personne glorifiée
en termes moraux
même
j'essaierai
sans
comme il est sans
et Dieu
nous traite ainsi
c'est cet amour
insistant
de Dieu
qui nous sanctifie
c'est pas les menaces
de Dieu
il n'y a rien
qui manque
pour cette personne
et là
je ne sais pas
comment vous dites
l'expression
quand on finit
un jeu vidéo
là
Annette peut m'aider
quand on va conclure
il n'y a pas
une expression
pour ça
non
quand on réussit
jusqu'à la fin
et on finit
les trucs
on a déjà réussi
dans la vie
si vous voulez comprendre
pour nous
tout est déjà
déchiffré
nous sommes déjà
héritiers
notre vie
est cachée
en Christ
Christ en nous
espérance
la gloire
on n'a pas besoin
d'attendre
beaucoup plus
de choses
pour cette vie
notre coeur
est déjà là
l'accessibilité
autour des jeux
est déjà
en réalité
pour nous
l'amour
de Dieu
déversé
dans nos coeurs
par les saints
esprits
en Christ
est déjà accessible
nous ne sommes pas
focalisés
sur des choses
à venir
si ce n'est que
l'intensification
des réalités
déjà accessibles
pour nous
et voilà pourquoi
les chrétiens
assurés
de cet amour
enracinés
dans cette joie
il peut voir
aussi sa relation
avec les autres
facettes
donc non seulement
la joie
elle est
enracinée
dans cet amour
mais la
la relation
de la joie
avec les autres
facettes
du fruit
de l'esprit
elles sont aussi
importantes
donc la joie
elle est
nourrie
par toute autre
vertu
du fruit
de l'esprit
mais attention
elle est aussi
celle
qui nourrit
surtout
toutes les autres
choses
donc pour faire
simple
montre-moi
une personne
qui manifeste
toutes ses facettes
je vous montre
une personne
heureuse
joyeuse
ou
montre-moi
une personne
joyeuse
et c'est impossible
que cette joie
ne se manifeste pas
dans toutes ses directions
la paix par exemple
elle nourrit
la joie
quelque part
car il y a
possiblement
aucune
raison
principale
dans l'expérience
humaine
pour les manques
de joie
que les manques
de paix
par exemple
les personnes
peuvent aller
vers les plaisirs
mondants
pécheurs
mais ils n'essaieront
jamais
en paix
avec eux-mêmes
pourquoi on vit
dans la génération
de l'intensité
des distractions
des divertissements
pourquoi même
les légalistes
ont besoin
d'être
si actifs
tous les temps
car ils n'arrivent
pas à s'arrêter
dans une chambre
pour écouter
leur propre pensée
leur propre conscience
si vous êtes vraiment
converti
et vous avez
un passé
pour plus
cautériser
qu'il soit
la conscience
humaine
moi au moment
dans mon expérience
beaucoup avant
ma conversion
ma vie était caractérisée
par par exemple
la superstition
c'est quoi la superstition
manque de paix
c'est l'idée
au fond de nos coeurs
au fond de nos pensées
qu'il y a
un dieu
contre nous
avec raison
syndrome de panique
la peur
que quelque chose
de mauvais
se passe
pourquoi
car on sait
qu'on n'a pas la paix
donc on est en train
de réjouir
de plusieurs
bonnes choses
du monde
avec les manques
de paix
et donc
c'est clair
que la réconciliation
avec Dieu
par l'évangile
est l'une des plus
grandes sources
de joie pour nous
car on a finalement
trouvé la paix
et si nous rentrons
dans un environnement
religieux
où la paix
n'est plus là
la joie
ne sera pas là
attention
névrotisme religieux
Dieu contre nous
mais c'est plus intéressant
aussi de remarquer
comment cette paix
elle est nourrie
par cette joie
car en réalité
attention
c'est la joie
d'une relation
assurée
avec notre Père
Céleste
qui nous donne
la paix
envers la vie
ne soyez pas
inquiets
le serment
de Jésus
contre l'ancienneté
toute son emphase
est mise
sur la paternité
de celui
qui régit l'univers
si nous avons
les dieux
qui gouvernent
chaque atome
de l'univers
pour père
si son esprit
nous a déjà donné
cette assurance
expérimentale
de savoir
que nous avons
la joie
d'avoir
Dieu
pour père
cette joie
nous assure
que tout
va aller bien
tout
et la patience
c'est aussi
une autre expression
de cette réalité
car la patience
la Bible nous dit
en fait
que la patience
elle nourrit
la joie
car notre joie
se trouve
dans l'espérance
une espérance
assurée
des réalités futures
qui vont sans doute
se passer avec nous
et donc cette joie
dans l'espérance
c'est car cette patience
cette endurance
cette persévérance
nous rappelle
que la récompense
de la patience
de l'endurance
de l'espérance
sera toujours
la meilleure récompense
pour les chrétiens
donc notre joie
est dans la récompense
de persévérer
d'être patient
on remarque
combien Dieu
a été patient
vers nous
et nous ne pouvons pas
nous empêcher
d'être patient
vers les autres
et donc la joie
elle nourrit
la patience
car
attention
une personne
véritablement satisfaite
elle sait attendre
le Saint-Esprit
nous est promis
donc ceux qui utilisent
des excuses
peu importe
combien soit
l'étendre
qu'il a dû endurer
et attendre
pour que quelque chose
se passe
les circonstances
difficiles
ou les temps
d'attente
ne justifient
jamais
l'infidélité
ou
Joseph
a manqué
des joies
d'accessibilité
à la présence
des dieux
pendant
toutes les périodes
d'attente
c'est qu'il nous donne
l'assurance
que nous pouvons
tout endurer
c'est la réalité
de réjouir
constamment
de cette joie
en dieux
Paul
qui a appris
à être content
en toute situation
la patience
et la satisfaction
exprimée
par l'endurance
par la période
d'attente
car notre
joie
ne dépend pas
des changements
des circonstances
ni des bénédictions
qu'on espère
mais elle est toujours
à la portée
donc une personne
vraiment joyeuse
elle peut être
comme Joseph
comme Moïse
comme David
des hommes
qui ont dû
attendre
des années
et des années
jusqu'à ce que
la promesse
faite à eux
s'accomplisse
donc la patience
nourrit la joie
la patience
elle nourrit
par la joie
la bonté
c'est l'une des choses
que les chrétiens
doivent les plus
saisir dans la génération
c'est que la bonté
selon la Bible
signifie plutôt
la sainteté
être en ordre
fonctionner comme il faut
et c'est là
où nous trouvons
cette joie
de pouvoir
plaire Dieu
de manière concrète
les vrais chrétiens
n'ont aucun autre but
plus élevé
sachant qu'ils a
aimé des dieux
qui de vouloir
produire les plaisirs
dans les cœurs
de Père
les plus sans
est en chrétien
les plus joyeux
il est
on n'est jamais
selon la Bible
encouragé à chercher
directement la joie
la joie
elle est toujours
un résultat
de la sainteté
les purs de cœur
verront Dieu
Satan
c'est lui
qui a voulu proposer
des plaisirs
immédiats
à Christ
dans sa tentation
toute la gloire
des royaumes
mais la Bible
elle nous pousse
toujours
à chercher
la sainteté
pour avoir
les plaisirs
même les bénédictions
que la Bible
nous promet
qui peuvent venir
de notre progression
sainteté
en montrant
que nous sommes
comme Salomon
par exemple
parce qu'il a prié
en demandant de la sagesse
pour gérer
les peuples
de Dieu
au lieu
de demander
de la richesse
et Dieu
lui a donné
les deux choses
car par la sainteté
nous pouvons
devenir plus aptes
à recevoir
certaines bénédictions
et donc
la bonté
elle nourrit
la joie
car à la mesure
en progrès
sans sainteté
les plus joyeux
nous sommes
mais en même temps
la joie
elle nourrit
la sanctification
car
à partir du moment
où les saints esprits
attestent à notre esprit
de manière expérimentale
que Dieu
a son plaisir
en nous
il n'y a aucune
motivation
plus puissante
pour la vie
du chrétien
qui est désiré
plaire davantage
les pères
la bénédignité
c'est cette joie
de donner
de se donner
de servir
et donc
le plus on s'exerce
dans la bénédignité
et le plus
de joie
on a
plus heureux
c'est celui
qui donne
comme l'a dit
le Christ
et malheureusement
les chrétiens
n'expérimentent pas
cette joie
car ils n'osent pas
servir plus
ou être plus généreux
dans leurs dons
la bénédignité
c'est de promouvoir
les biens
de l'autre
et la Bible
nous enseigne
que c'est là
où on trouve
la plus grande joie
c'est là
où Christ
va trouver
sa grande joie
et en même temps
si on est vraiment
joyeux
et débordant
c'est impossible
de ne pas agir
comme Dieu
Dieu n'a pas créé
l'univers
car il avait besoin
d'autres choses
pour être dans la joie
il a créé
l'univers
afin de maximiser
davantage sa joie
car sa joie
était débordante
par la bénédignité
nous démontrons
notre richesse
et les personnes
qui ont de la difficulté
à vivre
pour promouvoir
la vie des autres
ce sont des personnes
qui montrent par là
leur manquement
leur manque
de satisfaction
de joie
et donc la joie
c'est ce débordement
envers la bénédignité
on peut penser
à la fidélité
comme étant quelque chose
qui est
la nature même
de la vraie
fidélité
c'est la joie
d'être proche
des anges
pensez
dans un être fidèle
vous pensez directement
aux anges
toujours accroché
à la présence
de ton nom de Dieu
en attendant
la moindre possibilité
de servir
sans que ça puisse
traverser dans leur pensée
l'infidélité
car ils savent
que l'infidélité
produit leur éloignement
du plaisir du père
c'est d'attrister
les saints esprits
pourquoi on a
en génération
parfois
les soi-disant
pasteurs même
si infidèles
possiblement
car ils n'ont jamais
connu véritablement
les plaisirs
d'être considérés
fidèles
l'apôtre
quand il va décrire
son appel
il ne va pas
pointer envers
ses vertus
de personnel
il va dire
c'est lui
qui m'a considéré
fidèle
pour rendre service
c'est la joie
du chrétien
du vrai chrétien
de savoir
qu'à la fin
des comptes
il va dire
vous avez été
fidèles dans les peu
et vous serez
récompensés
avec beaucoup
rentre dans les
plaisirs
des enseignants
fidélité
la douceur
c'est la même chose
elle nourrit la joie
à la mesure où
les douces
ce sont ceux
qui se rassemblent
les plus à Christ
c'est lui
qui étant rassuré
donc la Bible
nous explique ça
de manière très claire
sachant qu'il venait
du père
et qu'il revenait au père
il a passé
à laver
les pieds des disciples
c'est à dire
si nous savons
vraiment quel est
notre héritage
quelle est la source
de notre joie
quel est le fondement
nous pouvons faire
les travaux
les plus humbles
nous pouvons
même nous livrer
pour être persécutés
on n'est pas là
pour défendre
notre droit
pour promouvoir
notre image
pour nous défendre
nous même
on est là
pour faire promouvoir
l'hérosion des dieux
par la douceur
bien heureux
les doux en esprit
car ils hériteront
la terre
ce ne sont pas ceux
qui vont faire la guerre
ou les conquêtes
ce sont les doux
et c'est clair
que c'est donc
cette joie
qui nourrit
la douceur
il faut être sûr
en fait
que vous réjouissez
dans votre héritage
dans votre partage
un dieu lui-même
et la tempérance
n'est rien d'autre
que la satisfaction
en dieu
s'exprimant
envers
une relation
les thermomètres
pour
l'aspect glorieux
vraiment d'une vie
dans la pratique
une vie des joies
en Christ
c'est que tout
est mesuré
par rapport
au plaisir
qu'on vise à provoquer
en Dieu
et tout est mesuré
par rapport
à ne pas vouloir
attrister Dieu
ou le Saint-Esprit
en cherchant
dans toutes les airs
de la vie
dans toutes mes interactions
avec ce monde
à nous permettre
d'un côté
de nous réjouir
des bonnes choses
avec Christ
et de l'autre côté
à avoir
une prise lâche
pour nous
pour nous dire
une prochaine goutte
une prochaine forchette
un peu plus
de temps
ici à cet endroit
ce n'est plus
un plaisir légitime
c'est pas la menace
c'est la mesure
de la joie
où je peux dire
je suis ici
en train de réjouir
de ces choses
avec Christ
je suis en train
de plaire Christ
et donc il y a
ce rapport
envers la joie
et toutes les facettes
du fruit de l'Esprit
enraciné
dans l'amour de Dieu
révélé en Christ
et cette joie
qui nourrit
toutes les autres facettes
et cette joie
qui est nourrie
par toutes ces autres facettes
et ce que nous cherchons
lorsqu'on cherche
à voir
les fruits de l'Esprit
chez nous
manifester
amplifier
les fruits de l'Esprit
ce qu'on cherche
c'est de maximiser
la conscience
de la joie
que nous avons déjà
dans l'amour de Dieu
et d'augmenter
cette joie
en nous rendant
aimables aux yeux
des dieux
vous êtes avec moi ?
on va devoir revenir
au sujet de la joie
une prochaine fois
pour penser
de manière plus
claire
ou plutôt précise
à comment cultiver
cette joie
et nous allons
nous arrêter ici
aujourd'hui